[موسيقى]
الكثبان الرملية تشبه أمواج المحيط الذهبية ،
كل واحدة مختلفة ، كل واحدة مميزة ،
كل واحدة لها سحر ، اسمي ديفيد
إلك ، وهي نظرية أخطط للقيام بها ستة في
نهاية المطاف على أقل من القيام
بها ، إنها شيء مختلف عن الماراثون العادي
لأننا نقوم به  في منتصف
العدم عندما تمر عبر هذا الأمر
يتعلق بالعقلية أكثر من المستوى البدني
أكثر من مستوى اللياقة البدنية ، لذا عليك
أن تكون قويًا عقليًا ، أعتقد أن
أهم الأشياء التي تحتاجها
لإنقاذ جسمك من الإصابة
لا تتحرك حتى ولو مرة واحدة  ثانية من التركيز
تساوي خطوة أمامية واحدة ووجهك
هو أحد الأشياء الرائعة التي مررت
بها حياتي يمكن أن أشعر أنني أطير
بين لحوم البقر وسعادتي في هذا
النوع من الرياضة هذا النوع من البيئة